pop
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir après 46 heures
de cauchemar à l'école maternelle de
neuilly les policiers du raid ont libéré
ce matin les six filles est encore
retenu en otage ainsi que la jeune femme
médecin du corps des sapeurs pompiers de
paris qui avait passé la nuit avec elle
et dont loin entendront le témoignage
tout à fait capital
le preneur d'otages a été abattu de
trois balles dans la tête précis du
dénouement avec valérie gas g4 petite
fille effrayée accroché au cou des
policiers du raid
il est 7 heures 25 nous assistons sans
encore le savoir al épilogue de la prise
d'otages ces enfants viennent juste
d'être emportée de la salle de
maternelle où il était détenu
apprenant que le ravisseur a été tué le
petit groupe regagne ensuite calmement
le parc de l'école à peine 30 minutes
plus tard edouard balladur le premier
ministre se présente à l'entrée
principale une courte visite suivie de
celle de son ministre de l'intérieur
pressé par les journalistes charles
pasqua est laconique mais heureux et le
forcené
les familles des petits otage sorte
ensuite une à une leurs n'est pas aux
grandes déclarations mais à l'émotion
qu'il était très content très content
à 8 heures on ignore encore les
conditions réelles du dénouement
nicolas sarkozy le maire de neuilly qui
a participé aux négociations apportera
un premier témoignage sur le ravisseur
il s'est beaucoup tendues et là ça fait
maintenant près de 18 heures qu'on
n'arrivait plus à sortir un enfant et
c'était plus facile au départ parce que
comme toutes les deux heures en arriver
à en sortir
et puis tout d'un coup c'est bloqué il
s'est dit ses enfants c'était sa
protection voulait plus en sortir il y
avait plus rien à faire ça il voulait
plus rien entendre on a tout essayé j'ai
été chercher l'argent
il était très méfiant il est toujours
content et il a voulu absolument que je
lui donne les le montant des devises en
deutschemark 1 et en dollars- enfin bref
et des discussions qui étaient irréels
puis on aperçut enfin ces deux femmes
exemplaires eglin lambert médecin
capitaine des pompiers de paris et
laurence dreyfuss la jeune institutrice
côte à côte comme sur cette image
pendant 47 eur elles ont protégé les
enfants en fin de matinée l'école avait
presque retrouvé une allure normale
la rentrée des classes et pour mardi une
rentrée sourire aux lèvres
on l'a vu le ravisseur avait mis en
place un dispositif de dynamitage
particulièrement sophistiqué mais aussi
totalement machiavélique celles et ceux
qui ont pu le rencontrer le décrivent
comme quelqu'un de très froid de
déterminer selon afp cet homme âgé de 42
ans s'appellerait eric schmidt il
portait sur lui des documents signés
human bomb ce qui explique les initiales
hb que signer les mémos qu'il avait
remis à la police
renaud fessaguet l'homme qui angoissait
la france pendant deux jours s'appelait
eric schmidt
il avait 42 ans était d'origine pied
noir c'est lui qui a échafaudé seul sans
doute cette opération suicide face à son
ordinateur
il voulait être entendu des médias et
pourtant personne avait prêté attention
à sa première action publique l'attentât
le week-end dernier d'un parti ni à
neuilly signé de deux initiales hb
individu a précisé qu'il était bien
l'auteur de l'attentât commis le 8 mai
dernier dans le parking de nuit au cours
d'autres confient l'art notamment de
l'entretien qu'il avait tué avec le
médecin capitaine des sapeurs pompiers
il avait précisé que le tig hb utilisent
étant pour revendiquer l'attentât donné
au profit ni les documents remis lors de
la prise d'otages une bombe humaine
voilà ce que voulais tu es très riches
mettent une idée fixe une obsession même
puisqu'en début de semaine il avait
annoncé à france soir et la police
une action d'envergure ce fut jeudi
matin à neuilly dans la maternelle du
commandant charcot plus tard dans ces
protocoles de négociations avec la
police
schmidt réclamé la démission du ministre
de l'intérieur puis une rançon de 100
millions de francs en laissant entendre
que c'était l'argent qui l'intéressé
avant tout en fait ceux qui l'ont
approché ont surtout noté sa
détermination son calme froid
sa paranoïa aussi une chose est sûre la
bombe
humaine avait envie d'exploser pour qui
pour quoi à moins de confidence faite
aux négociateurs
eric schmidt pourrait bien avoir emporté
avec lui son secret
[Musique]